bienvenue dans le village pittoresque de
Saint Gondon dans le Loiret un village
chargé d'histoire et de légende
d'ailleurs je vais vous raconter une
légende c'est la légende de l'ermite
gondulefus alors si tu permets la
légende raconte que l'Hermite de Bon
Dieu dessus vivait en forêt proche d'ici
et c'est disciples avait enterré son
corps dans la forêt et puis ils ont jugé
que ça n'était pas digne d'un saint donc
ils ont ramené les reliques de reliques
à Saint-Gondon et c'est dans du
transport de ce char funèbre que qui
était tiré par une vache et un cheval la
vache a gratté le sol et c'est de là
qu'a jaillit la source miraculeuse du
bon sang
c'est moi qui devait raconter ça
normalement ah bon non l'histoire c'est
moi qui la connais c'est vrai bienvenue
dans Juan en roue libre
un petit peu doux de la rivière comme ça
j'aurai de la chance mais non
ça Gondon était censée guérir la cécité
la stérilité ou la goutte les gens
venaient de Giens pour prélever de l'eau
et emmener chez eux et boire chaque jour
un verre d'eau ah d'accord c'était
considéré comme un mot magique mais
jusqu'à la fin du 19e siècle d'ailleurs
Maximilien de Béthune le ministre
d'Henri IV qui était seigneur de Sully
et de Saint-Gondon abus de cette eau
pour soigner sa goutte mais est-ce que
ça a marché ça malheureusement
l'histoire ne le dit pas où est-ce que
tu m'emmènes pour la suite de la visite
de ce village pittoresque on va les
visiter l'église direction l'église
bienvenue dans Juan en roue libre
alors Juan comment tu es tombé amoureux
de ce village depuis la chambre où
j'habitais on voyait un monument j'ai
été intrigué et je me suis renseigné à
un habitant qui m'a dit oh mais ça c'est
un temps de pierre sur un temps de terre
alors qu'en définitif se tertre de terre
c'est de la terre qui provient du
premier fossé de défense le ravelin et
donc de fil en aiguille je me suis
passionné pour le village même sur les
réseaux sociaux tu es intervenu je poste
des photographies avec l'histoire des
personnages qui sont sur ces photos et
maintenant je vais avoir une émission
Juan enroulée d'accord ouais c'est sacré
percé sacré percé une carrière s'ouvre à
moi bien sûr
tu as aussi une anecdote à me raconter
sur les pieds là ici là il se trouve que
une époque la municipalité a autorisé
les habitants à prélever des pierres de
cette mode féodale qui est maintenant
classée historique pour construire des
bâtiments et donc elle a été en quelque
sorte dilapidé de sa structure la voilà
cette magnifique église elle a traversé
le temps la partie la plus ancienne et
bien ce sont les abscies des absidiens
qui étaient la chapelle qui est derrière
et donc au fur et à mesure le cœur 13e
siècle la nef 16ème siècle au 19e siècle
le cloche autrefois le clocher se
trouvait au milieu et on accédait à ce
clocher par le tour de l'horloge qui
comme on peut le voir date de 1763 et là
vous avez le calctoire qui est aussi
dans la tradition Berrichonne cactoire
parce que l'entrée et à la sortie des
offices religieux et bien les gens ils
cachotaient
ils parlait
enrouliment n'est pas fini direction le
prieuré
ce prieuré est classé monument
historique en partie puisqu'il date du
15e et 17e siècle et bien voilà les amis
on était à 5 dans l'émission les gars
c'est super franchement c'est Roanne en
roule libre c'est ça exactement
merci de rien au revoir